hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a candy crush jelly saga level 20
walkthrough with commentary I'm going to
talk about level 20 strategy and it's a
puff leurs level so we're going talking
about puffers in general so i'll put a
link to my puffle errors video at the
end of this too because there's some
more stuff than that but for level 20 in
particular we got a hole in the middle
so we got two puffs fleurs we can see
from the meter in the in the underneath
the eyes so just going to try to figure
out where they're at first and one of
those alright so we have one there and
now it's up here so that's the first
thing that we want to do is after every
match we make one pay attention to where
they go so they're always down here we
can just go ahead and play this one
straight forward just go ahead and drop
this and save that one and the other
one's right up here and he's going to
end up right over there so one of the
things that is going to come in handy
later especially is when you can sort of
trap them where they are so you know if
I don't have a match that's going to
keep it in place I can do something like
this because this cuts the two halves of
the board apart and I think he's right
here if I remember so you know this
whole makes things a little bit more
Titan middle so I'm go ahead and shoot
that over there now remember the fish
won't go directly after it it's just
like bears they go just ice but now we
have them trapped in this little square
right here so we should be able to go
ahead and free them up just by planning
things out so it's one of those levels
that can seem pretty hard when you first
start playing it but if you break it
down it's not too bad
and you know the general this general
trip tips are to figure out where he's
at first once you do that try to pay
attention to where he goes after you
make the match and then once he use in a
place you want to try to keep them there
if you can and just pick away at it
until you get both of them free fill up
your meter at the top and you'll be able
to beat the level so i'll put the link
for the puffers video right here and
please subscribe to my channel and like
the video if you found it helpful thanks